[Música]
Estas son las noticias de France 24 ya
son al menos 40 las personas fallecidas
a causa del paso de la tormenta helio
que ha afectado gran parte de Estados
Unidos en la zona urbana de Búfalo en el
estado de Nueva York siete personas han
perdido la vida Aunque hay reportes
oficiales de hasta 28 personas
fallecidas
cerca de 70 aeronaves militares chinas
han incursionado en espacio aéreo
taiwanés en las últimas 24 horas el
hecho ha generado preocupación en la
región se trata de la mayor incursión
militar de china en cielos aéreos de
Taiwán recientemente
y por segundo día consecutivo miles de
personas protestaron contra el bloqueo
por parte de azerbaiyán del único
corredor terrestre que une a la
autoproclamada región de hashtag con el
mundo exterior que ha estado ya
bloqueada por 15 días provocando
desabastecimiento
muy buenas noches Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González Gracias por estar con nosotros
hasta ahora vamos a comenzar en Estados
Unidos porque ya son entre 40 y 50 las
personas que han fallecido a causa del
paso de la tormenta Elliot que ha
afectado gran parte del país con fuertes
vientos Nevadas y bajas temperaturas las
condiciones climáticas extremas
afectaron cerca del 60% de la población
de Estados Unidos justamente para las
celebraciones de Navidad el estado de
Nueva York es el más afectado por las
condiciones más detalles en el reporte
de Rafael Pérez
continuará el clima extremo en Nueva
York así lo hizo saber la gobernadora
del estado kaydy hocket que pidió se
declare el norte del estado como zona
catastrófica cualquiera que declare
Victoria y afirme que esto se acabó es
demasiado pronto para afirmar que esto
está por terminar tal vez la severidad
no sea la misma y este momento no sea
tan malo como lo ha sido en los últimos
días pero sigue siendo un problema
peligroso para estar afuera es la peor
tormenta que afecta el estado desde 1977
cuando un evento similar mató a casi 30
personas el comisionado de policía en
Búfalo se refirió al orden interno de su
territorio
estamos al tanto de los informes de
saqueos hemos visto algo de eso en redes
sociales nuestros oficiales han
respondido a varios informes hemos
realizado algunos arrestos hemos
intervenido en algunos de ellos las
imágenes se ratifican la fuerza de la
ventisca del siglo como ha sido
calificada por las autoridades la
guardia nacional se encuentra en la
localidad de Búfalo que bordea el lago
Eric uno de los sitios más afectados
para trabajar en el rescate de personas
atrapadas por la nieve miles de vuelos
fueron cancelados este fin de semana
festivo en todo Estados Unidos en el que
millones de personas se movilizaban para
festejar la Navidad La tempestad provocó
que al menos el 60% de la población
estadounidense estuviese bajo alerta por
el clima y más de un millón de personas
se quedaran sin energía eléctrica
Hablamos ahora de Brasil porque la
policía de ese país encontró una serie
de explosivos justo en las afueras de la
capital la ciudad de Brasilia se trata
de El tercer intento frustrado de un
atentado en los últimos días todo esto
previo a la toma de Posesión del
presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
que tendrá lugar el primero de enero el
Ministerio del interior o el ministro de
interior entrante dijo que las
autoridades van a garantizar la
seguridad en esta toma de Posesión la
cual se espera sea atendida por unas
300.000 personas han restribillo nos
cuenta más
Brasil se encuentra en alerta máxima a
unos días de la investidura de Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva como nuevo
presidente del país sudamericano la
policía desactivó una serie de
explosivos encontrados A las afueras de
Brasilia
Esta no es una acción individual y no lo
permitiremos en Brasil
y no es el primer hecho similar un día
antes un hombre fue detenido cuando
intentaba detonar un artefacto explosivo
en el aeropuerto de la capital brasileña
de manera casi paralela un empresario
Fue capturado tras confesar que había
plantado una bomba dentro de un camión
cisterna de combustible para provocar
caos e impedir la toma de posesión de
Lula el primero de enero en la cual
participarán unas 300.000 personas
incluyendo varios jefes de estado
desde que líder progresista fue elegido
para su tercer mandato en octubre los
grupos bolsonaristas más radicales se
han concentrado frente a cuarteles del
ejército pidiendo un golpe de estado que
evite la investidura de Lula
debemos anticiparnos a ciertos actos
porque no puede haber un vacío de poder
esto no va a pasar en la madrugada del
primero de enero vamos a tomar medidas
para que no se dé esta situación de
inestabilidad
también el Ministerio prevé una nueva
regulación para los clubes de tiro los
cuales se han incrementado desde 2019
según señalan las autoridades
en otros temas en las últimas 24 horas
cerca de 70 aviones de la fuerza aérea
de China incluidas aeronaves de combate
y drones entraron en la zona de defensa
aérea de Taiwán así lo reportó el
gobierno de La Isla que indicó que se
trataría de la mayor incursión de
militares chinos en espacio aéreo
taiwanés
naves del ejército chino entre ellas
drones y aviones de combate como de
costumbre china Está realizando sus
maniobras militares en el estrecho de
Taiwán imágenes propagandísticas y
maniobras que pretenden presionar a las
autoridades de taipei que dice seguir de
cerca la situación 47 de estos aviones
cruzaron la línea del estrecho de Taiwán
y entraron en la zona de defensa aérea
de La Isla se trata de la tercera mayor
incursión registrada desde principios de
año china ha realizado más de 1700
ejercicios de este tipo Beijing culpa
las autoridades taiwanesas de
provocaciones y colisionar con Estados
Unidos el sábado china manifestó su
firme oposición a un proyecto de ley de
defensa estadounidense que permitía
destinar hasta 10 mil millones de
dólares en ayuda militar Taiwán La Isla
aspira a independizarse de su vecino
chino pero Beijing pretende reunificar
su territorio Washington reconoce la
unidad de China pero mantiene estrechos
lazos con Taiwán desde hace décadas las
tensiones aumentaron cuando Nancy pelosi
de la cámara de representantes de
Estados Unidos visitó La Isla a
principios de agosto desde entonces las
relaciones diplomáticas entre Beijing y
Washington se han deteriorado aún más la
presidenta taiwanesa sai inhuen convocó
Este martes un consejo de seguridad para
estudiar la posibilidad de reforzar el
sistema de defensa civil de su
territorio y seguimos hablando de china
porque el gobierno de Beijing anunció
que a partir del 8 de enero serán
eliminadas las cuarentenas de entrada al
país que Se mantenían para prevenir
posibles contagios de covid-19 esta
medida tiene lugar en medio de la
reciente ola de contagios y de
fallecidos que ha desbordado totalmente
el sistema sanitario chino y que llevó a
que las autoridades dejaran de publicar
las cifras oficiales ante el supuesto
desfase en las estadísticas lo que
generó críticas a nivel internacional
Y nuevamente miles de personas salieron
a las calles del centro de este panaker
la capital de la autoproclamada
República de artash en nagorno caravag
los manifestantes rechazan el bloqueo
por parte de activistas hacer bailanos
de la única vía de acceso terrestre que
tiene esta región lo que ha llevado a
una grave en una grave crisis de
desabastecimiento de alimentos y de
medicinas el informe es de Andrés
triviño
en multitudinarias protestas miles de
personas salieron a las calles de esta
panaker la capital de la autoproclamada
República dearstage por un bloqueo al
corredor lachin la única vía que conecta
la disputada región de nagorno caravag
con Armenia
Este es el único camino que conecta Art
Touch con el resto del mundo no solo
Armenia llegamos al resto del mundo a
través de Armenia la situación es muy
grave pero la gente sin embargo intenta
aguantar
la autoproclamada República de arstáceo
se encuentra ubicada en la frontera
entre azerbaiyán y Armenia pero es
habitada por una mayoría étnica Armenia
Por lo cual es territorio de disputa
internacional
el corredor la china ha sido bloqueado
durante casi dos semanas por
manifestantes azervellanos que protestan
en contra de las minas ilegales de la
zona Pero los dos países entraron en una
guerra en el otoño de 2020 por el
control de la ruta Armenia acusa a
azerbaiyán de querer provocar una crisis
humanitaria
los habitantes de la zona ya empiezan a
sentir los estragos de casi dos semanas
de bloqueos
gases de medicamentos alimentos para
bebé pañales medicamentos para la
presión para adultos no podemos atender
a todos adecuadamente liberamos los
medicamentos en pequeñas cantidades
los bloqueos del corredor Vial han
aumentado el temor de una nueva guerra
en la región en septiembre de 2022 los
combates en la frontera entre ambos
países dejaron cerca de 300 muertos
la justicia francesa presentó
oficialmente los cargos contra el
atacate atacante confeso de tres
personas curdas en el centro de París el
ex conductor de trenes de 69 años se le
ha imputado los delitos de asesinato e
intento de asesinato por motivos de raza
etnia cultura o religión entre tanto las
calles de París la capital francesa
fueron nuevamente escenario de
manifestaciones en rechazo a este ataque
la comunidad kurda insisten atribuir la
autoría del ataque a Turquía o mejor
conocida como Turquía país cuyo gobierno
ha condenado este suceso
con esto llegamos al final de las
noticias aquí en France 24 siga con
nosotros
[Música]